so do you feel like you kind of haven't
stopped thank God I'm not a wedding
processor and I said it over and over
again but I the second we decided to
actually have a wedding I was like okay
I don't really care about most of this
do you and he was like nope and I was
like let's get a wedding planner was it
as magical as you expected it to be yeah
it was I ever thought that I wanted a
big wedding and I'm so glad that we had
one it's funny because obviously our
sophomore album you know it has quite a
few songs or a heartbreak yeah is it
weird now singing those songs that
you're in love and then marrying it in
this great relationship I am so grateful
for that person and that relationship
because I would not appreciate or
probably even be with Morgan like I just
I feel like I feel like every
relationship has a purpose I really do
think that and that relationship was for
me to like learn what I do and don't
want and how I should and should not be
treated and making Morgan right after
that was like I was able to appreciate
him like I should
[Music]
what's it like I know your untoward Lady
Antebellum you know when people like
that adopt you because you know those
are really globally yeah significant and
acknowledged acts I have pictures with
them as a fan and I feel like just to be
able to you know off like wait in line
for them when I was like was 13 years
old to meet them and save up to buy
nosebleed seats to see them and then be
able to open for them and then go do the
same thing like go to the sound booth
and wash them every night there's
certain people that I've broken through
the artists thing with and we know when
we're in artist mode but we also like
with proper friends Hilary's one of
those say there's some of those with me
like I just I have a couple where we got
through it and I love them and respect
him as artists but we're actually it's
like sweatpants friends you know yeah
the sweat pant loving star isn't letting
her lifestyle go to her head even as she
preps to go on tour with Keith Urban I
made a promise with myself when I signed
as an artist that I was gonna be the
same person on Instagram that I was on
stage that I was out to dinner really
early on like I posted about drinking
wine which sounds silly but like I just
wanted there to be this like openness of
like this is who I am and I like I
really try to be a good person and I
drink wine and I like you know I'm human
yeah a wine drinkin human who delighted
fans with surprise covers as she did
promo for the tour and she still can't
believe her luck
[Music]
enjoy
[Music]
he literally came to us like eight
months ago and he was like we're doing a
tour I want one opener I wanted to be
you and I was like done whatever yes
hard yes Wow she's awesome super cool
guy I'm gonna be surrounded by
Australians this year
so many
[Music]